hey 42 here if you've ever come first in
a particularly
difficult pub quit or aced a test that
had your friends tearing their hair out
you'll know how good it is to feel like
the smartest person in the room
just imagine that what it would be like
to be able to proclaim
that you were the greatest genius
in the history of our entire species
sadly 99 billion 999 million
999 999 of us will never be able to make
such a claim but somebody must be able
to
the question is who
at eight feet 11.1 inches tall that's
2.72 meters
robert wadlow is the tallest person to
have ever lived
jean louise calment is the oldest she
died at 122.
the heaviest person was john brower
minoch who tipped the scales and
probably broke them beyond all repair
whilst he was at it
at 100 stone or 635 kilograms
no prices for guessing where he was from
i tell you these things not because i'm
a malfunctioning
fact-based automaton that allegation was
never proven
but to make an important point you can
find the pinnacle of humanity
in almost any category in the guinness
book of world records
but what you won't find no matter how
long you spend flipping through its
pages
is an entry for the cleverest person
that ever lived that's because like the
male genitalia
on a particularly cold day genius
is incredibly tricky to measure probably
the most well-known method for
quantifying intelligence
is the iq test unfortunately iq tests
were only invented in the early 20th
century
meaning the majority of the most
promising candidates for the
42 greatest genius in history badge of
honor
only have estimated scores and
if we're honest iq tests aren't the best
measurement of intelligence anyway
take william james cetus born
in 1898 as a prime example by some
estimates at least he had an iq
of 300 the highest of any individual
in history to put that into perspective
albert einstein is thought to have
clocked in somewhere between
160 and 190. william cedars was reading
the new york times before he turned
two and had taught himself eight
languages
before he was ten and to put that into
perspective
at age 10 i was perfecting my technique
for armpit farts
at age 11 cedis became the youngest
person ever
to attend harvard and within his first
year
his professors were comparing him to one
of the greatest mathematicians in
history
carl friedrich gauss but if cedis was
such a singular genius
you might be wondering why you've never
heard of him
for starters he had the world's pushiest
parents who devised a gruelling
forced learning program which they
commenced
on the very day he was born and when he
escapes their clutches in getting into
harvard
he found himself head and shoulders
above his peers intellectually
but only running around their ankles in
terms of general life experience
and those all important social skills
when he eventually left the education
system some years later
he retreated from public life and worked
at menial jobs to make ends meet
despite his remarkable intelligence he
contributed
very little to humanity's hunt for
knowledge
he did write several books but since one
of them was the most complete treatise
on
streetcar tickets ever conceived we
probably shouldn't lift it
up there alongside darwin's on the
origin of species
cedars was without a doubt a remarkably
intelligent man
there's even a theory that he was the
inspiration for matt damon's character
in goodwill hunting
though he may have had the higher iq you
won't hear many people claim
william cedars was a genius on par with
the likes of nicola tesla
inventor of the tesla coil the first
alternating current motor
perhaps if he'd had a hand in designing
the cyber truck
its windows would still be intact and
there's another problem with relying on
iq scores to measure
genius many of them favor specific kinds
of intelligence like
mathematical ability and spatial
reasoning
and if we take a look at the wikipedia
page for the word
genius we quickly see that the pinnacle
of human intelligence
is about more than being really good at
solving annoying little black and white
puzzles
the page has portraits depicting nine of
humanity's finest minds
amongst them we find confucius a chinese
philosopher and one of the most famous
thinkers in history
cervantes spanish writer of one of the
most well-known novels in history
don quixote bobby fisher an american
chess
prodigy whose period of dominance during
the 70s
is unmatched to this day stanley kubrick
a legendary filmmaker known for his
classics like a clockwork orange
the shining and 2001 a space odyssey
marie curie a physicist and chemist
famous for her work on radioactivity
and for being both the first woman to
win the nobel prize
and the first person to win it twice
aristotle a greek philosopher polymath
and student of plato
einstein a theoretical physicist who
developed one of the most foundational
pillars of modern physics
the theory of relativity and wolfgang
amadeus mozart
probably the most famous composer of all
time
who wrote his first concerto at age five
speaking of einstein his famous wispy
locks could have certainly done with
some hair loss treatment
and mozart well his hair was famously
fantastic so he was okay
i have a close friend who started to
struggle with hair loss in his twenties
and truthfully it really got him down
and he's not alone
did you know two out of three guys will
experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it
whilst you still have hair left you used
to have to go to the doctor's office for
a hair loss prescription
but now thanks to keeps you can visit an
online doctor and get the medication you
need
delivered directly to your door i like
keeps because it makes treatment super
easy
by delivering your hair loss medication
every three months
so you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose hair just yet
but prevention is key the faster you act
the faster you'll see results and the
sooner you start using keeps the more
hair you'll save
if you're noticing you're losing your
hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash
42 or click the link in the description
to receive
50 off your first order
and what do all of these people have in
common
well apart from being truly great at
what they did
and dead not a whole lot
some of them changed the world some
altered the way we think
others pushed back boundaries in their
fields and a few
developed new fields entirely
oh and one was really good at board
games what this list does more than
anything else is
illustrate the point that intelligence
comes in all
shapes and sizes who's really qualified
to say whether the overture to the
marriage of figaro is
more representative of genius than e
equals m c
squared now i know what you're thinking
if the answer to the question who is the
greatest genius of all time is basically
just going to be me stroking my mustache
and shoving a lot then what the hell was
i playing at when i decided to make this
video
okay you win let me make my way down
from this
frankly uncomfortable seat on the fence
if you were to
nip off and check the wikipedia entry
for genius right now
don't watch this video you might notice
that there is
one other portrait to be found there
that i haven't mentioned so far
and that particular portrait belongs to
a man
that perhaps more than any other
deserves the title
of the greatest genius in history
now i'll hold my hands up and confess
that einstein would
not be impressed with my scientific
method here
my suggestion for the most brilliant man
ever
isn't based on fact i can't claim this
man has
the highest iq of all time that his
achievements
definitively outweigh all others or even
that he's beaten the final level on
candy crush
but i think he makes a pretty compelling
case all the same
the man i'm talking about is one
leonardo da vinci
born out of wedlock in a tiny hamlet in
the tuscan hills not too far away from
florence in 1452.
unlike william cedars da vinci was not
trained from birth to be some kind of
mind ninja and in fact received no
formal education at all
but from these humble beginnings
leonardo rose to become arguably
the greatest genius amongst the
approximately 100 billion
human beings to have ever taken a lung
full of air on planet earth
but wait a second the greatest genius
you have ever lived
was a painter well not exactly
while leonardo was most famous during
his lifetime for being more than a
little bit handy with a paintbrush
that was actually a tragic
oversimplification of his brilliance
one that would persist for almost 400
years after his death
it wasn't until the 19th century when
thousands of pages of his notes
known collectively as leonardo's codices
were rediscovered
that the true extent of the great man's
genius
was revealed for the first time let's
start
with anatomy back in the renaissance
painting was a serious business
and anyone who's ever progressed beyond
paint by numbers will know that
recreating the world on canvas
is no easy feat with perhaps the biggest
challenge of all being in realistically
mimicking
the subtleties of the human form but
what better way to figure out how to
draw an accurate human
than to tear one to pieces and see how
all the wet bits
inside it fit together da vinci did
exactly that
dissecting some 30 cadavers in an
attempt to learn the secrets of human
anatomy
the medical drawings that came out of
these macabre procedures
apart from being considered some of the
finest ever created
pioneered a cutaway technique that was
500 years ahead of its time
and can still be found in medical
textbooks today
they also greatly advance human
understanding of anatomy
or at least they would have done if they
were ever published
da vinci made hundreds perhaps thousands
of discoveries about the human body
some of the most impressive of which
concerned the heart
he was the first person to recognize
that the heart was a muscle
the first to describe its four chambers
and their function
and his understanding of how the aortic
valve worked
was only confirmed by modern science in
1968 with the use of an mri scanner
oh and based on leonardo's drawings and
explanations of the opening of the
mitral valve
heart surgeons pioneered a new technique
in heart surgery
in 2005 da vinci's vitruvian man
may just be the most famous sketch
in the world aside from being iconic
the drawing accurately depicts the
proportions of the human body
it's an image you'll have seen many
times i'm sure but
have you ever looked closely at the
writing that accompanies it
if you find it a little hard to read
don't beat yourself up
firstly it's in 500 year old italian
and secondly like almost all of
leonardo's codices
the words are written in mirror script
meaning they can only be read
normally by viewing them in a mirror why
nobody knows for sure da vinci was known
to be ambidextrous
he wrote conventionally when using his
right hand and mirrored when using his
left as
one does some people think he decided to
learn mirror writing to stop himself
creating smudges
when writing left-handed and others
think he was trying to make his notes
more difficult to read at a glance it's
even been suggested that the act of
rotating the words in his mind
before setting them down on paper might
have helped him recall them better
in the future a slightly less famous
sketch of da vinci's is a map of the
town
imola what makes this map particularly
special
is that it looks like a snapshot taken
from an aeroplane despite the fact that
the wright brothers wouldn't take to the
skies for another 400 years
it's the oldest map drawn from this kind
of perspective
in existence and yet it's so accurate
that it can still be used to navigate
imola today
although it is hopeless if you're trying
to find a petrol station da vinci made
the map for the city's conqueror
cesare borgia who was so impressed with
the craftsmanship and ingenuity involved
that he hired da vinci as his chief
military engineer
and architect on the spot it was in this
post
that da vinci showed yet another side of
his brilliance
cutting edge technologies in his day
were things like the printing press or
the nautical compass
but whilst working for borgia leonardo
found time to invent
the concept of the tank design and build
the world's first humanoid robot knight
write up the plans for a precursor to
the machine gun
designed to overcome the difficulty and
time associated with reloading weapons
of that era
develop a diving suit made for breathing
underwater
and sketch out the first known designs
for the submarine
a self-propelled car and a helicopter
it's difficult to put into words just
how far ahead of their time these ideas
were
most of the concepts didn't appear again
for centuries
that robot night for example nasa used
elements of da vinci's design
to help build their first humanoid robot
500 years later
the list of leonardo's remarkable
observations
insights and inventions is almost
endless
he was the first person to explain why
the sky is blue
the first to use evidence for fossil
distribution to question
the long-held wisdom of the bible's
great flood and he even came up with the
idea that every action
has an equal and opposite reaction a
full
200 years before newton was even born
on their own any of these discoveries
ideas and inventions
would be impressive enough but taken
together it's almost
unbelievable that so much knowledge
could have come from the mind
of one man in an era where he often
wasn't building on the work of others
but striking out entirely alone
he was so far ahead of his time that
contemporary scientists simply
had no use for his ideas which is
probably why his papers were never
published and the majority of his
discoveries and inventions
remained hidden within his mirrored
scroll and his notes
long after others came along decades
even centuries later
and rediscovered them independently it
was german philosopher
arthur schopenhauer who said that talent
hits a target
no one else can hit whilst genius
hits a target no one else can see
he was talking in general terms but this
phrase describes leonardo da vinci
perfectly he invented things that the
technology of his time
wasn't even close to being able to
actually build
and found brilliant solutions to
problems that wouldn't exist
for hundreds of years take the parachute
for
example widely thought to have been
invented by louis sebastian lenomo
in the late 18th century but
flip through the pages of da vinci's
codex atlanticus
written in 1485
and you'll find a sophisticated sketch
of one
the design was tested in the year 2000
for the first time
and it worked perfectly and let's not
forget that
on top of all this da vinci is
considered by many
to be the greatest painter of all time
his masterpiece salvador mundi is the
most expensive painting ever sold at
auction
fetching a cool 450 million dollars
in 2017 and the last supper is one of
the world's most recognizable paintings
and finally of course there's the mona
lisa
without doubt the most famous and
treasured piece of art
ever created it's so valuable in fact
that a french
news channel 1 suggested france might
want to think about
selling it to ease their national debt
the estimated price they came up with
2.7 billion dollars that's
about equal to the gdp of a small
country
if leonardo had just been a painter he
would deserve a place on the list of
humanity's greatest geniuses
likewise if he had just been a scientist
or an inventor
but somehow he was all of these things
at once
and more he is very probably the most
diversely talented individual
to have ever walked the earth and
sickeningly enough
reports from the time suggest he was
even good looking
too some renaissance polymaths have all
the luck
so who's the greatest genius to have
ever lived
well the long answer is that genius
comes in many different forms
that it's impossible to compare
different disciplines and eras
and that trying to come up with an
answer to such a big question is
ultimately futile
and quite possibly stupid and the short
answer is just leonardo da vinci
thanks for watching thanks to keeps for
sponsoring this video
don't forget to check them out using the
link in the description